Hey David, won't Medicare for all killed jobs?
This is a really loaded question and I'm glad
to have the opportunity to talk about it.
There's this imagery of killing jobs that
is a very political imagery to be quite honest
with you because the reality is that all of
the time, governments, federal government,
state governments, departments of the government,
whoever, all the time decisions are being
made that have an economic impact and they
have an employment impact.
Sometimes we're talking about thousands, we're
talking about a thousand new jobs a but we
lose 200 but there's some economic gain or
some social gain from that change.
So number one, we've got to get away from
this imagery of quote killing jobs because
all the time as a country evolves, decisions
are made that create jobs and that eliminate
jobs.
They cause firings, they cause layoffs, they
create new industries, et cetera.
What we have to understand is that a lot of
those jobs that exist in the medical field
right now, which would be unnecessary and
thus would disappear under a medicare for
all system, are not jobs that are actually
providing for the greater good.
What I mean by that is if you consider medical,
uh, insurance, health insurance, fraud investigators,
medical, a billing and coding experts on the
insurance side, medical billing and coding
experts on the hospital side.
By the way, not all of them would go away
under payer, under many single payer systems,
they remain all of this bureaucracy plus the
profit that is implicit in the system.
That doesn't lead to better health outcomes.
It doesn't lead to lower costs.
It's simply yes, providing work to the people
that are in those jobs and it is work that
is being paid for at the expense of people
who are buying availing themselves of healthcare
services.
So would some of those things be eliminated
if medicare for all work to be passed?
Yeah, some of them would.
The economy would have to adjust in history.
This has happened many, many times.
I give this example often, and I think it
applies here, think back to the development
of the automobile.
The automobile was a much more efficient means
of transportation than horse and buggy carriages
or whatever you call them.
There were people who said this is going to
eliminate the jobs of the drivers.
A, I don't know what they were called of the
horse buggies.
Would that be a reasonable reason not or not
to allow cars to be developed or to prevent
the development of automobiles?
Of course not.
Ultimately, those individuals no longer were
in demand in that role of horse buggy drivers.
They were reintegrated into the workplace
in other ways.
Some of them probably suffered longterm unemployment.
That's true.
But we need to stop falling for this idea
that any policy that will result in any job
loss is unacceptable.
In fact, it's actually a very sort of center
right idea.
I mean, there's this infamous video of Milton
Friedman arguing with some college kid, uh,
where the college kid says, shouldn't there
have been consequences for some car company
that had, uh, a car that was dangerous?
And Milton Friedman said, okay, well hold
on.
So there was a negative consequence from the
car, from some kind of negligence.
Uh, how much should that car company have
paid to fix that problem?
If the car costs 10 grand and it costs them
10 grand to fix their problems, should they
have been forced to do it?
What about should they have co paid $100,000
to fix a problem on a $10,000 car?
At a certain point you get to this, uh, a
realization that there are going to be negative
consequences to doing the right thing.
And whether you're on the Milton Friedman
side of that or not, it doesn't actually matter.
The point is every single day decisions are
being made.
Policy is being effected where some jobs are
lost, there is some economic costs.
It has to be accepted in a country of 340
million people, anytime you make any kind
of change, there will be people who gain and
people who lose right now the losers are people
who can't afford to pay for care.
People who get substandard care, people who
are going bankrupt.
Because of medical bills and those who gain
are the for-profit insurance companies, the
elected officials that perpetuate the status
quo in exchange for donations and whatever
else.
Yes, some jobs won't be necessary under Medicare
for all the net benefit is gigantic and that
or some system like it is still the right
thing.
Even though there will be uh, jobs that will
no longer be necessary and we just have to
accept that and not fall for the right wing
talking point that it will kill jobs.
And by the way, that is a, that is an under
the defense of talking point.
When the right goes to Medicare for all will
kill jobs.
They've often already conceded some of the
benefits of just such a system in terms of
access to care and in reducing costs.
That's why they retreat to it.
And it is a very, very weak counterpoint to
some kind of nonprofit system.
The likes of which many countries have already
employed.
Let me know what you think.
We have a great bonus show for you
today.
Become a member or a patron.
To get instant access@wwwdotjoinpacman.com
or at patrion.com/david Pack, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.